vous pensez qu'en 2021 il est impossible
de ne pas avoir entendu parler de
lakovic 19
et bien détrompez vous c'est possible
c'est le cas de cet adolescent
britannique joseph al ville
il se trouve que ce jeune garçon de 19
ans a été victime d'un accident de la
route il ya quinze mois de cela
un accident grave pour lequel il a été
plongé dans le coma durant pratiquement
un an
à son réveil il ya quelques jours c'est
avec stupéfaction qu'il a découvert un
tout nouveau monde un monde avec des
masques des gestes barrières et 100
restaurants
s'il n'est pas encore tout à fait en
état de comprendre l'étendue de la
pandémie liée à la cobi 19 que sa femme
il est petit à petit a remarché tout en
lui expliquant à quoi ressemble ce
nouveau monde dont il ne connaît rien
comme canyon en ligne a été lancée pour
aider le jeune homme dans sa
convalescence durant sa convalescence en
plus il a contracté voilà que vit dans
non c'est ouf c'est une star en
angleterre la cagnotte c'est un trente
mille livres soit 30 points mille euros
et petit à petit il lui réapprennent les
émotions c'est à dire que ils l'ont fait
sourire une fois ils me disent pas tout
parce qu'ils ont peur du choc émotionnel
et où il faut qu'il apprenne petit à
petit à vivre ce qui est bien et moins
bien